relaciones económicas y guerra en
Ucrania los dos focos de los encuentros
entre Emmanuel macron Úrsula bonder
Legends en Beijing Francia intenta
aprovechar las buenas relaciones entre
China y Rusia Unidos por su interés en
acabar con la hegemonía de Estados
Unidos para encontrar una salida
pacífica a la invasión rusa de
ucraniana
estamos comprometidos y sé que ustedes
también con la carta de Naciones Unidas
y con los textos vigentes en materia
nuclear
y sé que puedo contar con ustedes bajo
los dos principios que mencioné para
hacer que Rusia entre en razón y reunir
a todo el mundo en la mesa de
negociación
el kremlin ya ha rechazado un diálogo a
corto plazo pero mientras ni macron Y si
logren que Putin se sienten en la mesa
de negociación el objetivo es evitar la
escalada nuclear
debemos respetar nuestro solemne
compromiso de no usar armas nucleares y
de no recurrir a la guerra nuclear y
reanudar las conversaciones de paz
Cuando sea posible la presidenta de la
comisión europea fue más dura en sus
palabras expresó preocupación por los
derechos humanos en el país y pidió
responsabilidad a China como miembro del
Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU
alineándose con las advertencias
repetidas por Washington
armar al agresor es una Clara violación
del derecho internacional es el agresor
y nunca debe ser armado Y eso dañaría
significativamente la relación entre la
Unión Europea y china
en el ámbito económico y en palabras del
presidente francés Europa quiere
comerciar con china pero como hace
Beijing tiene que ser capaz de
protegerse macron llegó al gigante
asiático acompañado de más de 50
empresarios franceses la aeronáutica
europea airbus o la empresa Estatal de
energía francesa odef son algunas de las
compañías que en el marco de este viaje
han firmado nuevos acuerdos con sus
socios chinos